oh I love these brought let me tell you
this dude a lot of people used to wear
other [ __ ] back in the old days people
wore sheet or something feather shadow
nothing bra before they had Underpants
Brendan you know people would just grow
out their pubic hair and just hope that
it would hold on to their penis but what
I'm saying is this now they have a
company called Mack Weldon do I call Mac
daddies yeah oh the data it's really
strong it's a it's a it's like that
working man's under way if you go to
work dude go to work in these because
it's better than what you're wearing
right now
yeah and Mac well and believes in smart
design premium fabrics simple shopping
it's so dang easy all I got on there BAM
mack daddy send a shape to my doorbell
for a beautiful [ __ ] so many times
dude it's like it's like it's basically
like gum you ever see that movie 8 mile
it's kind of like that but for your for
your body for your cross you get in the
front of your pants
no but they just they're nervous they're
just they take care of you but you're
gonna get that's like a rap battle yeah
it's like a rat somebody's gonna get
toasty yeah yeah I'm about you're nuts
you're comfortable you're taking care of
duty knows Mac well yeah man time up
design the premium fabric oh my lord it
is nice you 20% off your first order
visit Mac weld and dot-com enter promo
code cats wow that's a real deal to 20%
of that first order because these things
are Hardy and Gerti brah
you know it's like putting on about me
yeah they're like you but underwear
honest yeah Gerty Hardy yeah it's like
putting all its yeah it's like doing
that it's like me wrapping your nuts
yeah yeah so for 20% off your first
order to visit Mac Weldon and enter
promo code ka t s see your Mac Daddy
Jesus Brendan trying to keep the lights
on hey I'll tell you right now bro when
I get that meat box at my house like it
I go what's in the box what's in the box
I'll tell you what's in the box high
quality meat for your mouth meat for
your mouth bro yeah dude that Brad Pitt
pork chops baby what I'm saying is if
you want a box of meat to show up to
your house and surprise your ass get
that butcher's box daddy 100% grass-fed
finished be free-range organic chicken
this turbo we're talking dead animal do
those up but I can have a damn lamb
[ __ ] rolling up on your porch looking
for her knife bro bro they do the work
for you
this has already been shut down see ya
hey wild caught salmon not that regular
salmon yeah not the kind of salmon that
just willingly jumps out of the boat and
you know it out of the river and in a
boat and just beg you to take it home
and eat it you know it tastes like whole
salmon that don't want to beat a bro
yeah and there's nothing more offensive
than a turkey dinner I mean is it even
Thanksgiving without Turkey this year do
Thanksgiving dinner the right way with
butcher box yep Turkey that's gun killed
too none of this frickin natural death
but yes Chokin the chickens and we're
talking about Turkey that was
straight-up killed with a weapon yeah we
ain't talking about choking the turkey
out with your bare hands so you get him
he's like this in the box a Russia bruh
you know bro we do it humanely bro every
month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high-quality meats right to
doorstep man yeah we got all kind of
meat we got this red meat white meat
chicken beef you got it what is it me
butch box is a no-brainer the best meat
shipped right to your door which means
one less trip to the grocery I'll burn
your [ __ ] house down son you want
some meat sign up today and get a free
turkey plus $20 off your first box yeah
just go to Turkey butcher box.com /ke
80s or enter promo code k 80s at
checkout that's butcher box.com slash
Castro enter promo code cats at checkout
for that free turkey $20 off your first
meat bugs
Hair Spray Jim BB q where's that shirts
a big brown breakdown oh wow that's old
school
are you paying advertising chins chest
there's no yes that's but still though
you're walking around what's on the back
chin I disagree I disagree barbecue man
a lot of Koreans now they used to do a
lot more stuff you know now they just do
barbecue and she won't shut the [ __ ] up
about it oh yeah
Jim what'd you do this weekend really oh
wow what do you every weekend all he
does outdoors or indoors unbelievable
you know your boy Steve Aoki has Korean
barbecue in his house I think it is both
Wow oh yeah he has Benihana hey meat
grill one guy's Japanese one guy's
Korean what's the difference I got some
meat for you grill right here son yeah
yeah you got barbecue chin come on meat
on your grill dogs you just use my joke
as much my joke I've been using know you
said put some meat on your grill it's
the same joke but similar oh my god
what's up nothing my jokes apparently my
secondhand jokes bro your goodwill jokes
yeah man okay bro damn right you look
[ __ ] where's your axe you look like
Paul Funyuns dude oh you like somebody
who goes into a [ __ ] 7-eleven with an
axe and a [ __ ] big blue thought and
it's a coca-cola slurping it's all the
Funyuns you delinquent like bunions bro
okay disgusting I disagree but dude I
disagree you're excited for Halloween
oh yeah I'm excited man somebody hit me
up yesterday to say how do I
what do I do to do it the Obon costume
Oh pretty easy looks like a transgender
[Laughter]
transgender scarecrow you think I could
go for that you only gotta like about
spirit cruises they get bugs in them
dude that's the part I wouldn't like
about being a scarecrow and you don't
see that you don't see a lot of the
aftermath of it bugs in them wolves come
up at night and piss on them yeah it's a
dirty job somebody has to do it now
their sole job is to scare the crows
away cuz it just crows other ducks for
other animals other ducks fall for it
crows are dark ducks dude you know what
I'm saying
say whatever you want bro crows are the
dark arts of freaking parrots if you
need me I'll be over here
Jeepers Creepers dude jeepers creepers
what do you got MB per node you get
those peepers and that's an old what is
that Derek is that an old I knew it from
the jeepers creepers movies yeah no [ __ ]
Derek the movie oh I thought it's like
an old church song it's in that movie
though that's what I know every guy from
iPhones really what's the name Jason
long no just adjacent Justin Justin long
yeah man never shook the Apple thing did
he do who just a long yeah well yeah
yeah I think it was a child was he a
child star Justin long will use a child
when did those Apple commercials he just
looks oh he wasn't he's 50 17 well he
dated drew Barrymore for a hot second
everybody did though yeah true 41 she
dates him aliens his dude him and
freakin Zack and Miri Make a Porno
is the best yeah that's good I will go
on that adventure with you the gay
adventure okay he's so getting it so
deep Morna Fairfield Connecticut
father was a Latin professor today was
rich bro let's be honest though you
don't see nobody [ __ ] learning
Lattin in the [ __ ] ghetto bruh yeah
you know what I'm saying language only
yeah you're not in the ghetto when
somebody's like hism us get a Garrigus
you know it's very rare more Ebonics
yeah you don't see a lot of [ __ ] Latin
and spinners going around these days you
know you're not in the barrio you see
vatos rollin up with some Roman numeral
now do ya you got Halloween coming up
what are you guys doing in Korea Chan
for Halloween
just the country of Korea huh well North
Korea they can't celebrate it well can
they I don't know can you looked at of
do they have Halloween in North Korea
they do not Wow Britain saying something
and guessing really hot Italian they
don't really they can't do they don't
get TV over there bro they get a lot of
stuff you don't know about uh Halloween
in North Korea the holiday is not
traditionally celebrating all of Korea
of kids adults don't say anything about
North Korea though North Korea they
can't do [ __ ] dude 72 percent of Koreans
were interested in going to a Halloween
party thought about it yeah I thought
about it
well there you go crayon thought about
it you know I'm saying are there any
images that go along with this dear you
know what do they dress up as Americans
Cowboys I bet they're one costume and
it's Kim Kim Jang in nil or whatever
that guy's name is Kim Jong nil
are you doing thing for Halloween chin
nothing what but just 40 you are there
EPV was like yeah I'm going around dude
you got to get away from the grill bro
you ain't [ __ ] 42 dog that's that all
that [ __ ] get off the grill that's at
all that pet rod the what's the stuff
you put in a grill that Bunsen burner
gas [ __ ] uh petroleum baby petroleum
the propane cooking your skin down dude
chin here take hits of that propane what
are you guys doing now you guys are
drinking at these girls aren't you okay
you drink a lot gin
you guys drink soju
and who sewed you I thought it's a
friend yeah I thought was a friend of
you know I mean it would be crazy if
it's purified by a boy and they have him
drinking soju body yes oh no no jerk him
over here no Jude get over here spin his
mouth like a little baby bird
Kelly's definitely no cat is Halloween I
feel like yeah I just feel like you
always kind of have like you know like
you look at Nightmare Before Christmas
vibe yes
no no dye your hair wear different
outfits I could see you I could see your
boyfriend or husband or whatever you
have coming home and you flying off the
top rope in a [ __ ] cat suit or
something an attack maybe because your
name's cat also that's like a Halloween
see cause a Power Ranger yeah and cat is
a popular Halloween costume in America
the the most popular yeah also thought
relax on Halloween it's the kids
Halloween you know quit having your ass
cheeks and tits in my face yeah you know
Gary you'll get a give my baby ruth yeah
or you'll get a kid yeah what were you
thinking I don't I don't know no plans
as of right now zero I might end up
going to USC and just kind of party
hopping going back the old alumni huh
yeah go as Olivia J pretend like I
bought my way in oh I like that
that sounds fun the good kind of what
are you doing oh man I don't worth days
coming up side I don't when's your
birthday the 25th dog are you hiding a
oh are you hiring hi in life I've been
high every time he's like Cheech and
Chong yeah that really isn't dude that's
[ __ ] Derek dude he's like Derek and
Hassan both just smoke know this one guy
I'm talking to and he looks hi you're
under the influence of marijuana right
now yeah put a necklace on or something
when you're high side yeah yeah we're
some glass so we're we're a special high
hat yeah we're a bell under one of your
arms or something your birthday's to
25th what's today today is the second
yeah it's Friday you got three days if
you make it thank you cuz in their open
community a lot of young men don't see
what how will do you Derek
29 3 29 28 a lot of young men you'll see
30 in there that's a that's a Tupac
alert in that culture yeah
your boys ain't gonna make it to 30 yep
I made that up I made that up I forget
the letter and I looked over and
channels like this I it sounded with
with a pair of songs and [ __ ] beef
like this bro what I call sometimes a
pilot
sometimes the H doesn't exist bro
they're tall dude no thongs you didn't
live Halloween Korean barbecue you go
and do deal that could be your new band
you gotta get teriyaki songs baby
beeping tongs boy you know I'd go watch
beef and Tom drop a couple hit yeah oh
yeah chin on the guitar just shredding
it up D what do you do for your bday men
Thursday yes Isis New York places house
one night and it's all Middle Eastern
comedians suffer no Middle Eastern
community show huh no my girl has some
plans I don't know yet it might nose you
put down Friday what to do what do some
I don't about Friday night if I'm
available but we'll figure it out do you
really do anything
how do nothing I did get it out of use
your birthday yeah dude I don't do
anything for my birthday action I never
do you get sad on your birthday's I do
you do yeah I do okay so this isn't a
question from me then why won't you be
in the safe zone cuz I feel like if
you're running low on gas you get
depressed so yeah I didn't know
dude I've run out of gas by 30 times I
didn't know people didn't run out of gas
till about four years ago did I ran out
of gas and some lady like what the [ __ ]
are you doing boy you know yeah it's
running out of gas I was like yeah
always run around again
she's like I was like you know you can
only put so much gas in the car yeah
she's like no [ __ ] and that's why you
had to get more gas you know you're a
ran out and have to push the car so
embarrassed that's half my childhood but
I've run out of gas no joke probably 35
times so you got that ass yeah pushing
that car that'll build your goals I
gotta lose gas cheese baby [ __ ] 97
Fontaine boy tank on eg I got them tank
on easy boy
Derek your birthday man Jesus huh
twenty nine I made it Derek sending me
30 you you're gonna be 30 well I'll be
29 oh you'll be 29 yeah still not the
big three oh you're not that dirty so so
it's a Sun in that danger zone 26 27
okay
187 do bro sign of ties his [ __ ] his
whatever hair he has on him white dudes
[ __ ] 68 he hasn't hair does he well
you got beards pretty thick but no I
know you're on the hip Pro in the desert
you can live under a [ __ ] you don't
have to have water but I mean you very
little sustenance a lot of those people
yeah that's not okay yeah Hassan is
basically a cactus there's a Middle
Eastern cactus yes I don't think there's
cactus out there but whatever cacti they
called Shakti yeah he's a cactus boy
comic too good I can't believe what a
[ __ ] sad group were doing nobody's
doing [ __ ] for Halloween nothing dude no
what about you Playboy well that sounds
like a missile sounds like you
definitely don't have a plan no dude
there's no plan and what kind of party
is it like do you guys do it if you have
a party what kind of dude what do you
wish it to be like just people drinking
any weaponry or anything
[ __ ] yeah yeah like that well damn
doesn't sound like you've putting this
party together very well
hope he's providing the space bro he's
providing the roof over your heads oh
man
hisses crystal Papa interesting yeah no
one's doing [ __ ] palette but again in
one's a little older cat I thought maybe
was gonna have some that's why I think
maybe I think it's Loki I'm sub
naturally or somewhat ever it's called
hoping that cat is doing something so we
can live like your hat really knew her
well she going to USC though that's
where it gets pretty loose I feel like
you might run into Will Ferrell at a
Halloween party there I think you might
run into some fear old [ __ ] over
there dude oh that's why other people
doing cocaine out there what is it uh
mostly adderall and xanax oh wow even a
party yeah really yeah
XANA that's as a USC it's USC Brandon
they get everything but zip but zani is
what is it xanax is uh what is it the NX
a lot of people use for anxiety it's an
anxiety medicine so why would you want
to party with it a lot of you'd like to
feel loose yeah people don't want their
anxiety it we have to add a party
everything's idea to party because it's
a party loose that's the slope now
they're doing it with a quiz in it
because if you don't have anxiety it
then makes you looser than you naturally
are hmm so you're basically hi I take I
take Danny and you take my butt getting
raped what
well I'm Toulouse says her already you
know I'm saying I go USC on Brendan
listen to this right now probably get
raped - okay thanks to that probably on
zani yeah now you know not to take it
that's I known it I'm only saying it is
I think zannies also a popular Korean
name isn't it chin it's also a rapper
named littlez Annie littles Annie is
that little Zane no all of us guys die
everyone name it for a drug little
little packets No yeah a little whatever
if you have little your you're not
living a twenty nine little pesticide
little pesticide died a couple years ago
remember last year little propane yeah a
little propane a little prop little
skeet little skeeters people haven't he
drowned what is it show about that's a
yeah what do we do a real quick
can't have you done
no I thought about selling it to rich
kids [ __ ] yeah she's probably got a bag
of pills in her [ __ ] cooter right now
she's a no offense guys I was trying to
get her a hustler feet she's a [ __ ]
feet I sell pills son she's like you got
that PEZ dispenser baby lord of war over
there oh lord of wars good isn't it
that's a great movie shot Jared Leto
Danny okay the kids doing drugs then
yeah chilly get on them drugs I could
see these crazies bet he's losing his
hair too
are you really no he's not no no it
isn't June well you're just not growing
it you'll never know if it's then unless
you grow it again no look at me and feel
long here don't care
here's going faster though Derick
Sachin's you took his breath away broke
yeah no no you got a long time girl I
get that room but that [ __ ] is oh god
bless her yeah you got that [ __ ] head
Rick Douglas the hook and he's fearless
about it so I'm talking about you should
open up a barber shop bro come in and we
[ __ ] give you what you get well just
how that happens just have a sharp gun
and just [ __ ] cut people's hair real
fast yeah
shout out to Derek and chin for losing
their hair there except losing his hair
dude and neither his chin man
you said chin is I said Derek is that's
a the race to see who goes bald first
okay but chin chin has an advantage he's
40-something it's really not leaving he
just shaved his head you have that big
scar on your head
you're gonna be fine yeah you got a ton
of hair too over here party but I'm for
that
[Laughter]
it's got a [ __ ] Jew Ligeti grin over
here party hat
give him play over here dude he leaked a
little bit like Johnny Depp is doesn't
mean I think Johnny Depp is you get that
yeah yeah are you Native American no
he's not to be Latino huh yeah my
Negroes papa even either huh bueno bueno
[ __ ] day si papi see Brenda man
passing a Native American bro Native
American air that Apache hitter over
there suddenly that's yeah I will see
that [ __ ] Jomo son if you had a
hatchet or something yeah yeah maybe a
little Aztec but you can't accuse
someone to be an Indian if they don't of
a hatchet Brendon wear face paint out
there or face paint well face paint
anybody can have face paint you could be
it you can't be it like a party me like
are you Native American and somebody's
like no I'm [ __ ] you no no you can
only have face paint on I'm it's
Halloween you can only have face paint
off it's Halloween you know I'm saying
if you're not Native American you can't
wear face paint when you gonna wear face
paint what does it show about dude
that's what I want it it's about great
Halloween ideas okay and we have an
Oregon's okay here's what we come here's
our costumes right now my costume is
depression pretty much chin is uh
basically admitted to alcoholism and
we're beef around beef and thongs the
new bands you can see him live at the
film work I don't know what the rest of
our costumes are man what are you gonna
be Brendan you say I mean oh I'm the
boogeyman from Nightmare Before
Christmas my son's zero and my girl's
gonna be Sally Wow Sally Jessy Raphael
yeah I love that [ __ ] I started an
airport one time I was a classes on oh
yeah yeah [ __ ] yes you did and she's
starting to lose some of her faculties I
think and uh so she had a man with her
that was keeping tabs on her
Oh a handler yep remember back in the
day was like Oprah Sally
Jerry Springer Donahue y'all bro good
goes on he was [ __ ] fine as [ __ ]
yeah yeah he was good-looking dude but
back then all those daytime talk shows
were the [ __ ] weren't they
no Prahran the world back then now she
does a book club Phil Donahue right
there
did that he's dead no he is not dude
really
oh no he's alive he'll never die bro
he's alive
[ __ ] yeah 83 years old hell yeah
beautiful he's married to Marge Cooney
at one point he was married to Marlo
Thomas at one point five children coming
out of [ __ ] sweet Phillies d [ __ ] yeah
dude how many kids you think you have
inside of your nuts you'd think at one
time looking that up there I think it
just depends on the I'm where your blast
on it right those swimmers gotta compete
it's kind of like the movie 300
how many kids and you're nuts well yeah
I can't even believe uh I could have
only imagine some of their high school
term papers who's gonna have kids first
chin-hua Theo or Derek
yeah probably Derek cat says Derek why
cat why don't you weigh in business
let's get a woman's perspective you
someone with an actual egg you [ __ ]
because I think Derek's the only one
actively busting yeah right that's true
imagine better yesterday and nothing
it'll never be a nothing huh
nothing a plant nope enough feed
something you son of a [ __ ] I'm not
feeding something there uh Daniel yeah
for sure for sure Derek though you think
cat and then out of me and chin out of
me and chinny chin chin who stole his
name from my [ __ ] children's nursery
rhyme three little pigs
I think it's gonna be you Theo amen and
then afterwards change I don't know I
don't think I don't think kids are in
the book fortune first of all chin just
needs to find it don't hang out with
chin has to have kids you know his
parents will [ __ ] kill him bro so Ron
you about it I told you dude you're
right you know you're Koreans Hey
but aren't they worried that you don't
date anybody all the time what if I can
[Laughter]
be careful here just a bro like a blind
guy - Arkansas you [ __ ] wander sharp
Chubut you mean a knife store bro a
sharp sharp a sharp [ __ ] are you from
Bowie if you sell knives and just sell
knives sharp sharp are you [ __ ] sharp
[ __ ] dude
razor blade sharp plastic answer up chin
or get out of here are they're worried
cuz you don't date anybody ever they've
expressed a lot of concern yeah yeah
they know you have friends I don't think
you're a psychopath would you think dude
I saw him with a baddie one time I saw
that baddies mother or yeah mother that
was his mom oh nice I'm time brother or
yen yes I'm boy than you take care of
the taste town bear look can't we are we
what is this do we start the show we
start the show
I guess we're all throwing a Halloween
party okay that's that's all our plan
yeah we're coming here this guy's
throwing it me I'm a Theodore Oh Thomas
yeah Louise his name's Louise for those
of you that don't speak Spanish God like
bread white people yeah let's go we're
gonna party at Louise's road Louise says
I'm going streaking party at Louise's
cats bringing the drugs
Derek's bringing the haircuts chins
Shen's bringing the beef no no chins the
music bro yeah I been keeping thongs
beef at the head and we're bringing the
[ __ ] let's get into this here's a
white guy that has a problem let's hear
it Carter here's some guy in recovery
it's Nick Carter Carter I don't believe
that Carter from Marysville Marysville
Washington yo King in the stink
part of football season I came up with a
good debate for you guys to try who do
you think would be the better
quarterback Chris dance D'Elia or Andrew
cheeto Santino I think and you know the
redhead might be a better quarterback in
NFL but oh yeah her to be a good debate
for you guys so uh Gang Gang rub-a-dub
buzz buzz thanks guys rub-a-dub-dub dang
bro I'm gonna eat this it was this one
for me he's easy
cheeto Santino the ginger to remember
dude you know what I'm saying the
[ __ ] red Andy Dalton bro I think
you'd he's got more fire in him he
doesn't care what happens to him he has
seen more sports Chris doesn't like
sports Chris doesn't like he doesn't
watch doing anything or sports so but I
think Chris more athletic now what do
you mean by athletic looks athletic or
actually as athletic man and what type
of athleticism if you're talking about
somebody just swim romantically to the
bottom of a [ __ ] beautiful like ocean
area and pick up a [ __ ] conch shell
okay Chris okay if you're talking about
somebody to [ __ ] sidestep a couple of
[ __ ] crackheads in an alley somewhere
Santini and [ __ ] run the ball to the
end zone losing both of his arms in the
process
I don't care and not caring not even get
it to the end zone
yeah Santino Santino did grow up in
Chicago the streets of Chicago is a
redhead yeah and yeah he's got a
consideration he has some darkness about
him oh yeah anger there oh it's just cuz
he's redhead I've met some pretty chill
redheads
yeah you know not chill redhead yeah
that's true
here's a podcast about alcohol
look I think this is an easy one for me
man this is Santino if you're talking
about if your sport is someone to lay on
a cloud and finish a [ __ ] pudding
that they're not gonna like with their
shirt off not only feeding some pudding
to themselves but feeding something to
each nipple on their chest your sport is
[ __ ] wrestling a needle out of some
[ __ ] business man's arm in some shady
[ __ ] jewelry ice well that's not
football linebacker a shady businessman
with a needle whatever and doing a line
of coke in a Kia Sephia
as he [ __ ] argues with his [ __ ] wife
over FaceTime about their two [ __ ]
fat kids somewhere Dino this is a easy
one sadena all day you know yeah you
know what 55% Santino's pretty close
interesting up next we got de from
Ontario Canada oh I want to go to
Ontario too
hey Theo Brendan this is Dave from
Ontario was it whispering and I got a
debate questions not Brendon at least
he's in the gym by the snack machine let
me know what you think buzz buzz young
man by the snack machine at the gym I
feel how to hang out there too sometimes
I can see you dude yeah reload that
sugar levels um you're here shoulder
pressing these nerd ropes rock stars or
rappers as far as who gets more hoes
dude if it was the 90s rock stars 80s
rock stars all day dude think about the
rock stars back in the day okay so I
think you have to talk about rock stars
at that time they don't have rock stars
that's what I'm saying there's no rock
stars Nickelback doesn't count
well Nickelback also was a 20 year ago
reference I mean let's talk about a
recent rock star who's a new Marion
harder Nick harder yeah core of the
Carter three little Wayne is almost a
rock star now when you think about it
he's played more guitar than half the
[ __ ] other
you know guys who even went on tour
blink when they do right any any left
and yeah you know what the scouts to
life oh really
did you not think about this before you
jumped in with blink-182
all the small things the [ __ ] is
happening right now he's like I like to
skate but not this much skate till they
start playing the music everybody well
escape do you start doing some skater
[ __ ] the tight jeans don't make you a
skater a little Wayne man yes can you
think of a rock whose are us the biggest
rock star right now who's the redhead
with the with the with the [ __ ] up
eyes yeah ed Sheeran it's probably the
biggest rock star you got yeah ed
Sheeran rock star
well he's Jim you know music well get
well name a rock star he's mall rock
just just like name stone who's not pop
John Mayer maybe it well no Aerosmith
was hot in the 60s 70s 80s 90s I know
well no you breed Jared Leto thirty
Seconds to Mars thirty Seconds to Mars
six degrees of Saturn or whatever yeah
Mars what are you saying you saying post
below but I was like hey that's a rapper
really
he's rapper pop but post Malone's kind
of fair cuz he does do a little bit of
it dude yeah whenever yeah when we was
children they had to Led Zeppelin ac/dc
yeah journey bruh journey [ __ ] died
on the journey the whole pan bro dude
lead singer Korean now how about beef
and Tony broke day I remember these have
a magazine that kid would come to you
once a month and it was like pictures of
the ride and they've been fighting each
other with [ __ ] broken bottles dude
rock of love I went and saw no yeah
who's there delete the who's rep Michael
oh dude
Brett who Goo Dolls oh now then now
we're talking you know you lose jobs
around me you know you look similarly
you know I'm a [ __ ] mine of their
shows dude I follow him across I
followed them one time I followed them
across about 1/8 the Pennsylvania dude
I'm a day
slave I will [ __ ] follow Dave
Matthews to the end of Earth satellite
you're dating yourself Brit Dave
Matthews you'd like the Goo Goo Dolls
Dave Matthews you have the same stylist
take Matthew Davis appeared bro where's
that [ __ ] dude [ __ ] dude he's
selling out all over bro you album bro
did he where's the Goo Goo Dolls Goo Goo
Dolls are everywhere
they're performing somewhere yeah they
are so so State Matthews hmm yeah hater
yeah yeah I am but think about how big
rock stars we're back in the day there's
nothing bigger
there's nothing dude Metallica they're
still doing it yeah now it's a lungful
rehab or whatever so I think Rob but
then rappers get more like I think I
don't know rappers see me they get more
like those video vixens yeah nothing
better I don't know and they get those
IG hos - yeah
then big booty [ __ ] they slidin those
dm's whatever city they're in - Jesus
Christ
yeah man I booked this day it's just
it's a time thing you know you're
talking about the 70s 80s rock stars
destroyed what do you guys think let's
get some culture dance a rappers just
because rappers get all color chicks
black girls would never like [ __ ]
they were only [ __ ] white girls you
know what I mean black girls were only
[ __ ] white girls no Metallica was
like only [ __ ] white girls and ac/dc
like they're all white girls right they
didn't have yeah they didn't have black
girls coming to their audience right rap
is one of the few genres where if all
cultures will go watch the music yes
everyone everyone goes to watch it I
would say rappers are yeah rappers they
cover all demos everyone pop Suzanne
what was the guys question originally
specifically what was he saying he gets
more rappers or who gets word ladies
kind of an outdated question cuz there's
no rock stars - homeboys point post
Malone's could kind of the closest yeah
you know it's so tall it's tough to
figure that out man
it's very tough it's tough to figure
that out I don't know if we're the
people I asked no I mean you're a big
Goo Goo Dolls fan I'm PayPass yes I
think that says it all but I'd say
rappers buy how to go it's a John Mayer
though
the closest thing that we have and I
think he's obviously he's been with
every woman in the whole world so he's
probably so many people's dad I cannot
think of one Rockstar Chinni you're in
the music business
yeah chin [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude I'm
gonna take some of your hair out of your
head
yeah welcome to the new Korea dude for
every time you don't [ __ ] have an
answer we take a piece of hair out of
your head you know Travis Barker is kind
of the most rock guy he's who Corey
Taylor for the Titans know as Corey
Davis who is it
Oh Slipknot he still have a lot of those
I CPA me Jost he's telling a lot of
those skunk metal bands you know ICP
ink-stained Clown Posse you got a limp
Biskit Fred Durst Fred Durst busting
nuts no in his bedroom alone Fred Durst
whose bedroom alone he's not he's not
doing albums whatever dude I don't wanna
talk about it anymore yeah I don't it's
hard to figure out I think good call
though with insane clown posse I yeah I
don't know I don't know
green day green day go away Coldplay I
like oh boy yeah you got guys let me be
like James Blake I mean he's a he but
he's I mean it's just it's tough it's
like what is a rock star now it doesn't
exist the roof I've had him Levine he's
a rock star he's a rock star I think he
can play an instrument maybe that's the
qualifier fan of Adam Levine I'm a fan
of maroon 5 you are oh yeah he's
beautiful Adam Levine I saw him at
Halloween party but I'm straight so I'm
fine you went as a straight man yeah I
went my whole life as a straight man
dude real face dude
get me out of this question yeah 59%
rock stars house where they went that
day make sense back then
it's like we need a time period that's
true it's ridiculous question here's an
ad yo man
there's so much sports going right now
World Series MBA NFL your Saint
doing well the Patriots aren't gonna
lose ever and you can make money on all
this dude all that money just use my
bookie dot AG brah yeah now not if you
know if you have a problem gambling then
you shouldn't do it but if you don't and
you want to lay a little parlay then
this is a place to do it and parlay is
really where you can catch up against
the odds you know you get two or three
bets you like you lay four dollars on
$109 but it could turn out to be you
know you win eighty dollars
yeah and my bookie dot AG gives you so
many ding ways to win if you guys want
to support the show and you like to bet
on sports get in there with my bookie if
you join right now my bookie will double
your first deposit use promo code cats
to activate the offer that's promo code
cats to double your cash you didn't hit
it he'll get out there and do what you
got to do visit my bookie AG today I
think a good bet is maybe Detroit I
think a good bet is maybe them New
Hampshire [ __ ] cats brah sure knock
knock who's there
pantheon Brendan dude I'm so sick of
tucking in my shirt looking like a dork
these days yeah yeah and one of my
friends dude ah I think his name is John
Rosetti down there near Ross San Diego
he always says to me hey hey hey man
Owen tuck your shirt and look like a
king and guess what he's a doctor now
so it's science every wonder why
traditional button-up look so long and
baggy when they're untucked it's cuz
they're not made to be untucked ya Mon
Tucket shirts these shirts were talking
about were designed to be worn on tuck
so you look cool man you look cool but
you also look capable man I told you my
print as a doctor now dude and before he
had untuck it he couldn't even read bro
so here's what I'm saying dude you're
broke you're destitute you're in a coma
get on tuck it dude
next thing you know you might have some
oil money you might have a job you might
have a freakin you might have a second
wife you know you might have a new
Corvette anything could happen
but you got to start with your
appearance dude you're on tinder your
new tinder profile pic on tuck your
shirts the only chicks you get or Bros
do try it on in person at one of the
anti-gay it's 50 stores nationwide or go
to on Tucket com to get started
offer free shipping free returns on all
orders in the United States you can save
time self your first order by using the
code cats at checkout that's on Tucket
dot-com promo code cats untuck you it
ain't rocket science you sick little
pilgrims alright here's what you do
[Music]
[Music]
job this guy's great
we gotta meet this guy whatever cities
in we should do with live King and sing
him bring him on stage we know anything
about him
just Jay right he won't we don't know
where he's from I love this j-rod yeah
he's not he actually is mysterious he's
wearing panty on his head now I'm
confused I know what a furry is what's
the other thing a parolee tried to look
it up not a beard Peroni is a disease
that affects your penis I do know that
note severe Maroney a Brody breathe like
a bro me it's a male adult fan of the
hit 2010 show my little pony yeah and he
they take it to the max bro and that's a
real John but it's a real person when
they do sex everywhere wit these are
bronies
oh no it's Takashi 6/9 that's cool
that's Takashi Sigma and that's where he
got his look from and they told first
and those are first and now the furry
thing I could get into if somebody had
some warmth it's on the front dude cut
out the tits cheeks out the back I'm all
for that see a little fox fox that's
called molesting someone yeah you ready
you have to have full costume on to be
up to be involved I've read at some of
the different
terms and conditions and did I tell you
my friend was that the no my friend was
at the porno Awards avian and he's this
giant man and they go hey man we would
legit Rampage Jackson no nope they go we
do he's about 6 6 eh we'd love for you
to be in this porno and you can wear the
costume he's like man that sounds really
cool show my girls if I Godzilla [ __ ]
but just the dick is not the friends
like I can't yeah I guess he like this
self in the mirror was like I can't do
this I could see that being tough
two-foot yeah yeah you can't feel Jon
Gosselin furry Johnson yeah it was all
aging girls I wish she did it I wish she
did it he didn't but the point is is
that would be a furry I think dude eat
that brand muff I'm getting a bite of
muffin Brendon firs I'd listened that
I'm not familiar at all with the my
little pony
yeah gang I don't so they get together
and celebrate my little pony yeah it's a
whole convictive conventions for it but
hey cat knows about it how big is it cat
well you seem to know about it well
thank you yeah you seem pretty
knowledgeable I yeah I don't you said
they meet in Chino every Sunday this
team's yeah this seems like more up your
alley I feel like if you had to pick
someone in this room who would know
about this it's like a yellow birds like
I think I've never heard of this is this
is foreign to me as [ __ ] dude are you
familiar with this hey chin I'm just not
your head yes or no hey I just got to
know I I know what side I'm leaning on
chin lies lose to hair I like that idea
chin you're a bit you know dressed up as
a furry hey circle trust never mmm yeah
you damn right you have fur coat with a
mask you mean um so everybody wants to
lie in here that's fine that's fine
obviously not circle trust I would say
furry cuz I don't know the other thing
yeah deal I don't [ __ ] know man you
know I I'm not familiar
honestly bottom [ __ ] no dude ain't in
all this whack [ __ ] no you ain't finding
me I mean you can't drive with that
furry [ __ ] on because you can't drive
with them full costume masks on I tell
eagle I'm not doing that [ __ ] bro and
it's expect I feel like freebie
expensive
I love j-rod bruh but I don't like
furries I don't like bronies there's
only like 70 of them they meet up in
[ __ ] Charleston or whatever every
year wherever dude over there Phil yeah
dude
sweating their ass off in the costumes
yeah smoke a bowl of my nuts if you're
either one of those dude yeah yeah I
can't really either as well
j-roc sorry about your parents bro yeah
collect baseball cards and I am sorry
gay right that you were conceived by
both of these and have an e removable
panty on your head boy - I do love J run
what's thought is going there I don't
know either 35% furry it's close 55
people exacts Wow cuz you can be a brony
and then be a furry furry is all
inclusive man brownie brownie a brownie
yeah a brownie brownie be ro NY Wow yeah
like this spelling is gonna help Brenda
news to me dude I've never heard of it
maybe else you got a little clown my
hand boys Jesus first we got this is
Ludwig goddamn Ludwig got that cinnamon
sugar nose dream I lost the fight took
in him Ludwig when I was in middle
school was it Duane Ludwig cuz he [ __ ]
your well huh Ludwig look I think it was
double Ludwig I think his name was a
little love with love wig it sounds like
you guys got a fight at a mechanic shop
God look who's a [ __ ] dick on that
puppy huh oh no is that no that's just
an arm oh that's his nose or those is
nuts
those are nuts no well they shouldn't be
sending that that's disgust that's a
nice hell no that's a knight he's a cute
little hell were they asking about this
animal he's just that his weight
clownin he's 11 months old it's not the
clown because he's cute as his funds
could be those balls he's a clown I'm
nude he's showing us his [ __ ] nuts in
that middle picture on purpose he's a
shark think about two surgeries a snake
bite I'll tell you this dude I don't
need to Klein you cuz you know who's
climbing you dude the Lord okay to
snakebites you're doing something wrong
in life bro you got a couple months left
okay Gideon or what's the damn things
named Ludwig okay you bout to take a
[ __ ] pirelli to the next Sun okay you
better be careful in a neighborhood cuz
you got to catch up you've got to catch
a car dog stay off the curb you know
what I'm saying the Lord's looking for
you to snakebites and a [ __ ] cat
attack or whatever you go into heaven
yeah he's short leash for this you want
to show you nuts to people on the
internet bro that's not you can't bro
you can end up in [ __ ] jail boy you
gonna end up in jail with a couple of
[ __ ] brother dogs going at you ass or
six feet under Sun yeah are six feet
under boy gonna live that gangster life
with your nuts out you're gonna pay for
it so look this hound dude now I'm mad
like deal [ __ ] this hell bro I mean he's
I don't like dogs yeah bruh you know
what I'm saying get my ass for you out
there though he is cute though that
first one is cute they ain't grew up to
be a [ __ ] next we got Tyson boys this
is original name Tyson he's a boxer
right how did I guess there we go
and I'm at the hood yeah I'll tell you
what I hate the racial profile here by
seeing on the street I'm crossing I'm
crossing over the street I don't trust
this dude with the hood the marks not
trustworthy ya feel me I think he has
coke on his paws if you look at his paws
if we zoom in on the thief and the foot
I assume he's got a case pride as a
couple one two felonies Herron there
can't be trusted he definitely has that
kind of looks like he's trying to do the
right thing
[Laughter]
trying to do the right thing but it's
really hard from just quick cash is the
easy go for him
you got that Rocky Balboa look to him a
little he definitely you know what man
he's been through a lot but he's made
some poor choices dude he has a couple
kids he hadn't spoken to in a bit I'm
sure child support nope mm-hmm so look
at that he's got that little hoodie on
it looks like something from gap about
12 15 18 years ago
oh I don't trust him to turn that right
now he gots nice arms though if he look
at his frontal and we definitely works
out here's the prison build I don't know
if he's working arms good legs
this drug muscle I think oh you think
I'm always jealous of drug addicts oh
he's skinny you ever seen a fat drug
addict go never Chris Farley checkmate
bro you got checkmated no I'm talking
about nothing hold up oh and that's like
addicted to coke and meth you know I'm
saying yeah Chris Farley oh yeah meth
yeah he was like putting everything in
his body
well he's especially did but in general
that rare they're real skinny yeah he's
that rare element do christopher Farley
were talking about yeah you even eat
buried up there Madison Wisconsin I'll
say that but this fella right here this
Atlanta what's his name Cheryl
Tyson Tyson he looks like you selling
that [ __ ] zani with cats yeah this
little [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] this little yeah
cat seemed like you might date this guy
it seemed like that showed he want a
thigh is it your type that's my type cat
riding shotgun listen to the [ __ ] G
easy buckle me give the money what is it
animal that you love here kitty cat
yells hood doesn't it yell it yells hood
and he's mixed he looks a little bit
like French Montana a little bit yeah
it looks like he's a little bit of a
Philadelphia flavor maybe little York
flavor we've got that easy backsplash
you know just can't wait to tell some
buddies from Cuba yeah look at that look
at that very similar
yeah gang brah so he's weird me when he
drops the n-bomb
yeah no no no boys like what is
happening what him and Drake doing like
what is happening yeah guys you and earn
that yeah dude
yes you can't say it man no but this dog
can what else you got obviously this dog
is missed court a couple times nude and
if you don't take care of himself breath
things are only gonna get worse oh do
use on my 40% what are we doing no who's
on my flight I felt like coming up
through and just be like did we
celebrate your hits mean deal Vaughn
king of sing Nelly Nelly he was on your
flight you didn't say hey to him what
you didn't hate him I do I were like
this that's nothing nope he went like
this dude I saw tomorrow Epps know Chris
Epps was like other Mike Epps one time
Omar Epps yeah the comedian Chris Epps
my cat my cat my crate was I am either
oh I'm thinking of I can't remember
what's next Derek relationship advice
boys no God we helped so many people
this is Tony from Massachusetts
Massachusetts what about photos gang
gang buzz-buzz okay so I need some
relationship advice I've been seeing
this girl recently she's about 10 years
older than me who I've been into that
way that's a stripper wait what'd he say
sex is amazing she's a great girl she's
been going to school like long mesh then
the thing that makes me nervous about
her is she's really clingy and I don't
know if I'm just laying down the pipe
right or I'm someone she hasn't met
before it's really exciting it's really
fun it just she's a stripper
roping she's met so many dude it's
Brendan wanting to be with me every
night wanting to sleep over at Vava blah
you know you know how it goes nope I'm
sure my god I don't know let me know
what I should do about this situation
its kind of tough
you know make a judgment call on it I
Love You Man bang I appreciate you
calling in doing this guy seem like a
nice guy wears like something it sounds
like some fourth doctor drew but yeah
sure man
really yeah well here's the thing dude
he has stage five clinger it's a
stripper you the only guy in her life
says she can trust clearly probably
didn't have a dad let's be honest we
don't know do they have a picture of the
woman do you have a family portrait I
thought we did
we don't well that's news to me let's do
more work everybody I think that he
should just factor tragic over there
[Laughter]
typing like well we've narrowed it down
to everyone um dude be grateful the
chick wants to chill with you all the
time and and do fun stuff what is this
guy asking us I couldn't figure I was
trying to notate what is being a what's
being occurred so he's dating an
ex-stripper he's 25 she's 34 okay
she's clingy and bipolar but the sex is
amazing he just doesn't know what oh he
did say bipolar yeah he said she's
bipolar
oh you a doctor now too bro maybe she's
just Moody
maybe she's works late as [ __ ] like a
vampire so during the day she's a little
[ __ ] Bren they're not insane what do
you mean that's insane supers don't work
during the day
it's an insane question or answer they
do work some of them do work during the
day dude no those who shout out to those
ladies who are hardworking strippers
it's easy to be in there stripping at
night when everybody's throwing money
around you right you be in there in the
daytime when nobody's in there you're
right you're right it's like open mics
you know right shout out to all of those
daytime strippers bro you know them
sunshine workers days I'm a stripper
nation boy yes in yeah you UV you the
ugly ducklings of the club and that's
why is there during the day beautiful
their hard work and they have families
to their bust nope they're usually
busted and cuz notice it's the busted
sunshine hoes and prime rib go
hand-in-hand trying to get people in so
you can have a little meat and watch
these ugly
thank him Brendon that's a strip club
dude yeah but I see that I think you got
to see the beauty in all of them it's
not just about how there are you guys
Jamie come on down yeah
Jamie does her best he tries super hard
and she's a nice lady
you know she failed out of school but
who did and you know Jamie's learning to
knit and just filled up her car with gas
yeah he's really nervous
Jamie's nervous [ __ ] it doesn't want to
be here it's your money everybody that's
115 pick it up on a Thursday it's 2:00
in the afternoon she has a full [ __ ]
outfit on refused to take off her jeans
give it up for Jesse strippers I'm
talking about me to represent yeah you
ain't strip nervous yeah they're little
stiff up there you know I'm saying yeah
Ruthie's fantasy teams struggled this
past weekend she's really on a tough
time she had a goes for breakfast
Carrie is on break from Home Depot but
you saved me a couple extra bucks dude I
like those highlights that man to
emotional strippers really work in real
strippers yeah I go at night but I feel
you so what's this guy just basically
this guy was just telling us that he's
been doing good sex with a lady
basically let's go to cat let's get some
female or Sarah to her to Derek I mean
the stripper may look at him like he's
her future 401k like a retirement plan a
young guy doing well if he's doing I was
doing well or has potential to do well
he's younger maybe he's in a more stable
lifestyle than she is she just wants
someone to come home to dude you ever
you ever met some of those strippers
side zippers are smart man where they
get all that cast they got properties
and [ __ ] but not all of them are
unfortunately and then they got their
real estate license and [ __ ] on the side
I got a damn thing about buying this
house you get that blow out ass girl
like yeah you can catch me at diamond
Cabaret tonight I'll take the crib and
nook see a diamond cabaret girl it's
tough out there people are doing their
bad
you know it's really tough for a lot of
these ladies out there and uh you know
if we if we can do anything to help I
guess just reach out to us you know god
I feel like we're eight my stripper dude
they send in pictures of Elsa am i doing
all right you right you right that'd be
disgusting
well I'm just how bad is haribol you
know I don't need to do about what love
could help them or it blows them the
[ __ ] up the more dudes go and they make
crazy money and then they retire early
and we're helping one strip at a time
strip a thong nope that's a Spring Break
dude that's Andy dick [ __ ] brother
that's the kind of shitty Andy Dick does
you know nice ink ink looks got my
spitballing ideas here try to help this
kid out what does he need from us this
guy what was he asking us relationship
advice like about what like specific
down Oh he's dating a stripper she's
clingy bipolar he doesn't know what to
do should he stay with her should he not
stay with her I don't think it's gonna
be up to you brother to be honest with
you I I think she's driving this ship
yeah you go yeah dude I'm the captain
now look at my teeth yeah that was not
an impersonation huge and he thought it
was him I did too I thought
lose six hairs for thinking about
yourself yeah what I'm saying is this uh
you're gonna be fine dude
okay you're naked right now in this
video you don't have a [ __ ] shirt on
you're in bed if I can be man you've
obviously just beauty the masturbated or
recently calm clearly sleep on a food
tongue you're gonna be great and this
lady's gonna make the choice if she's
bipolar tri-polar you know that's how
they do it now you know strippers next
thing you know she [ __ ] saws your
arms off and they find you two years
from now and a [ __ ] body bag outside
of Gainesville so I like when their body
pillows give you a nice lap dance and
maybe come up with a business plan oh
yeah investing a few ideas okay so I
think yeah wait for those flying cars
Becky I bet
I think play it out baby boy let me see
how it goes bro yeah we hope he helped
you out and thank you for reaching out
to us man we appreciate the support and
I would like to picture a nice and
thanks for checking out King in the
sting too brother
yeah all right boys let's wrap it up
with some King intersting
not about that I never up first this is
kat dahlia yet daliyah hey boys so have
a king intersting it for you
my name is kat by the way so she had
i'll tell you girl i just into Ibiza
with my girlfriend
obviously had to progress the situation
yeah I couldn't understand I'm so
perfect
um so we go back to hotel room no yeah
we're taking it slow because I'm also
bad at sex P oh so it's not outweigh MBG
baby no bus gang sign he goes and I
can't do it they accent but I want to
pee in your mouth oh well but you got a
free gun your hands I'm sorry can you
repeat that
I wonder whiz in your mouth whiz in your
mouth you Harry Potter fan No
so King understand urinating anything
request for our Kelly okay
not for Theo and Brendan not my bag baby
you get a real freak on your hand just
off the bat who was doing it it's that
Boston birdbath right there no you know
that's not Jameson hitter bro
that's that Guinness in your mouth girl
oh yeah oh they'll get this yeah and
that's that Irish body wash doggy feel
that's a new day right I don't know man
wow I don't even know where to gun me if
you could test the urine and see you
know if there was a someone had a litmus
paper or something could test the urine
real quick if you chilled it it might be
nice I don't know I don't know where are
you know Russian escort you're drinking
killed piss out of somebody
yeah bro they're international waters
yeah just Ross and Ibiza you know that's
not my Posner song for you kids out
there there what what is going on I
don't know but you have an olive in
there with you thinking chilled urine
bras what you're admitted to right
sometimes they put one of those tequila
worms Mexico am i right hey that's a
tapeworm dude if you're drinking she
might be a lead rope I wanna know did
she do it oh yeah hmm I'm golden showers
probably pass for me again if it's
chilled might be a different story
never had it never been offered it look
it's urine until you're in an avalanche
and then it's Dane dick wine you know
it's a full as body wine at that point
yeah avalanche with somebody dude every
every ounce counts every trip in my crib
counts you'd be serving so you can serve
a family of four if you just had a
[ __ ] you know two bottles of
Niagra or whatever that well it sounded
racist but bottled water my god dude of
water here's the thing man
I don't like right now between I drink
so much coffee when I got a pee I gotta
pee dude some girl asked me to piss you
can Splash Mountain girl my [ __ ] is a
super soaker I'm knocking out teeth
there's black guys next thing you know I
get arrested being on girls that's not
doesn't go over well in prison it's a
terrible idea man yeah you feel me look
yeah nobody got that weak stream Bravo
yeah you get new that sprinklers you're
getting Splash Mountain as you say I
also heard that for this is what I've
heard you're also getting it's a small
world after all brother okay all I'm
saying is over here you get mr. Toad's
Wild Ride that's sexy in that Magic
Mountain baby you been smoking again huh
no
you've been smoking no I had a black
lung pop no I have it so so good luck
with your parade look here's the thing
if you're on drugs or whatever I think
if you have a little that's fine ain't
gonna kill you I don't think have a lot
though I mean if you have a hat you know
quarter cup or something or you know
half a cup or whatever you guys a party
that's what I'm saying
chilled shots of piss chill it out no no
no I don't think I should be doing
recipes and stuff for you you know
measuring it out and to us you know
that's be in the moment yeah it's a
momentary action you know let's go to
the culture corner see what do you guys
do in your country you guys when I pee
would I be in a girl's mouth man no girl
ever asked you don't put his Gertie's
girl as a human being that has to live
the rest of her life I don't think
actually she loves it that's her thing
that's how you okay and what if they
break up in here and then she has to get
a job two years from now I'm like hey
girl yes that's exactly what could
happen you're right when you're right
you're right yeah thanks for looking out
for me and her sorry man but I mean it's
up to you guys you pee on some in the
shower yeah I've done that oh yeah and
the show
oh yeah you know done that either don't
be immature yeah dude you're too almost
29 it's time start living you don't pee
in the shower it's I don't it's not
right but all the fun thing about peeing
on something your showers they don't
know you're peeing on yeah man the water
you got warm on the Sun that's it's
peepee baby yeah people like yeah they
don't know they have shampoo that's not
so fun like their eyes are closed
yeah use the other bag a little like
what are you doing bro wait what so
those are college days dude what you
didn't count solitude is it a white
thing to pee in the tub because I don't
do that [ __ ] I nobody pees in the tub
yeah mommy's does yeah it's so
refreshing I've done that I love peeing
outside too man oh oh I love peeing
straight up in the air not even
wondering where it lands at you know no
on the whole piecing in the mouth dog
cat Jesus guys I don't want to hear this
kind of stuff man
cats know so no one's into it all right
I don't want to hear this kind of stuff
well I think if a woman is into it if
they discuss it with you or something or
that you know i think i think it's a
spur-of-the-moment type of thing i don't
think you got you know people need to be
planning ahead and you know drinking a
bunch of water the day before and all
that kind of stuff no asparagus yeah
yeah i can't have that i think good like
a moment i would like to follow up
though
and did you do it how'd it go the irish
will drink anything to does she say the
guy's irish 30 was Irish oh yeah come on
bro it's almost Scottish man what else
we got up next we got Scott from Clinton
can we get out of this show this is a
night from before what's up Brandon
what's up Theo I'm in the st. Lawrence
Seaway in the Upper Canada upper Quebec
what's this question no eyebrows dinging
for ya
whale-watching gang gang buzz-buzz
blowhole Wow gang gang buzz-buzz
blowhole dude blowholes dude uh thank
you for reaching out from québécois
brother oh yeah
wailing oh dude there's nothing worse my
family went whale watching we see one
[ __ ] whale and Sawyer stepmom hours
jump off the side of the boat uh what
the guy's saying we're watching good or
bad interesting good for senior citizens
I think good for senior citizen
something easy for them to do oh the
whale you watch it basic calm not gonna
do sit there you have to talk that much
not that exciting yeah I've seen it too
much too much on the internet on TV
whales or whatever
listen if he can't no whales or not
whatever I know if you can't kill me
I'll kill [ __ ] now if it's a great white
popping up little seals and [ __ ] and
it's like daughter
whales are God's sea bass brother okay
what I'm saying whales are gods shorts
or sea bass though you know your dude
think about if you're an idiot or not
[Laughter]
I'm sorry Madison has said that man day
I'm just a little bit I'm not tired even
I just not if top state for though you
know yeah not any day they're gonna why
is a struggling hopefully one of these
decades you know I'm gonna get a decade
off one of these days yeah I hope you do
too man maybe should go whale watch and
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah actually I'm probably a good idea
for me it might be relaxed and dude oh
just watch them and that's it did you
see him you're like mm-hmm it's pretty
fun to harpoon them now that's an Asian
thing is it Japanese part Asia mm-hmm
but Japanese do kill whales they kill
the [ __ ] out of them well they're fish
attackers bro all don't they think their
fins are like aphrodisiac yeah
they got extra dick in the fin but I'll
say this I appreciate this guy sending
this in this is also the guy who sent in
the first video no one else noticed that
and once again I don't think is oh I
don't think so
I think there's two white dudes in your
racist really it's White's ISM yes not
in the video is there a whale no I look
there was a whale in the video I look
like you just you guys are all [ __ ] up
Brendan I'm sorry no I'm in the st.
Lawrence Seaway in the Upper Canada I
think my moral back is good and I got a
king under stinger for ya whale watching
Derek is the detective agency no they
got shut down there it's just two guys
playing basketball against each other
okay no I got shut down cuz they give me
fear how to unlock the door - good call
in the whale I catch up for his either
I like staring at his eyebrows he's on a
boat in the st. Lawrence channel yeah
shut out the whales oh well why it's
definitely slow and boring but uh
Qingyun I think you have to do some
things you go do when you're old or
something is you go doing you're younger
if you have access to whales right there
brah go look at them don't swim with
them yeah it's like I like it to go see
the crack you know go see the UM the
crabs sometimes in Louisiana because
they're right there but if you otherwise
do old stuff later you know you can make
a puzzle later I ain't making a puzzle
now that much yeah I'm making a small
puzzle ain't making a [ __ ] 60,000
piece puzzle you know you know [ __ ] your
crossword - you're over 60 well I mean
you could do a crossword game if you
want to stay busy but don't be doing it
all day don't do a 6,000 word any graham
crackers yeah king it whale watching
it's an age thing
last one boys this is Aaron John it's
the longest show of all time
airing I sent a lips on her she's on
zani at all eggs
she's awesome she's my favorite person
that wasn't gonna hot big brown
get back in there dude you know well no
dude let's see that hair leg again is it
real hair on this edit it in that was
real it could be edited was that is that
considered a lot of hair let's go to the
culture corner we're here then my leg
look I'm asking dim Brendan nothing
definitely more hair to my leg - but I'm
witty girl you like dancing I don't know
I don't even it's just the fact that she
did it so [ __ ] huh you'd let your
girl girl here oh really yes she doesn't
but I mean she does it she's all shaved
up but if she did you see it this kind
of confidence wouldn't I be with it
mm-hmm Oh sexy what I'm so irate right
now okay you're not hearing at all just
in general right no Asians really don't
grow hair like that mm-hmm
but look I get where she's coming from
because it takes forever to shave your
legs so I don't blame her but I don't
like hairy legs personally but Bernie
you have to imagine you're making love
to a woman and you get to hold on to her
legs and they have hair on them you know
but also imagine it's real cold outside
okay no just not that's such a hard note
for me yeah it's a note for me - I think
if you like you feel sick physically ill
let's see one more time make sure that
it's hair on there it's not a hairy
person you get a stomach look at her
armpit may not jugs are Brenden now I'll
say wait hold on play this again is that
her leg dude are we getting duped dude
you should be a detective yeah no that's
her like no no no no hold up hold up
play it again feels on the side hold on
play it again
cuz she's not a hairy person look at her
other leg posit when you see both legs
pause go a little more does she go
anymore did we see any more of that
other leg man I don't think that's her
leg I think feels right cuz her other
leg doesn't even move looks like a man's
leg to me that might be a man dude this
is the dress blue or is the dress a
zebra you know what's that thing that
always happened yeah you right we can
put this one out to see what people I
have to put this on social media can't
say is this her leg cuz there's a couple
of things going on here first of all she
seemed like a beautiful young lady and
everything like that super prom second
of all Shh she takes care of like her
teeth and everything so much you know
she looks like taking care of she have
phones I think some spray tan or a hand
tanner where you rub tanner into your
body yeah look at her tummy yep and then
also look at her hand when her hand
comes in it looks like it has some of
that brown like tanner rub on it you
know that uh
it's almost like that jerk chicken stuff
you put on but you put it on your body
you know the occasion reasoning yeah but
women put it on him to look kind of like
brown at night or a brown during the day
and then they it gets all over your
sheets sometimes yeah chocolate butter
yeah chocolate body so I'm not lying if
this leg looks like a woman's leg
because it's not as tan as the rest her
body either
well her hands [ __ ] widen can you go
out is there is there any more to pull
down our scroll up or down on this video
itself is this we had that hairy leg
gate right now I'd like the fans maybe
maybe she could stand in another video
Oh little stubble though is that stubble
though or is that actual hair that no
zoom in we probably can huh God somebody
can we're oh no no no her armpits hairy
I'm out I'm out then you know how you
get disguised about butt sex and come
and [ __ ] this makes me disgusted brain I
don't want to be part just say all
today I was having a good day as well
yeah you weren't
now some girls have a condition like one
of Charles Manson's family members who
commit some of those murders how to
condition her legs were hairy [ __ ] yeah
who cares dude they murdered a bunch of
people saying she had hairy legs the
only other person I've known today that
doesn't mean that they should be a lot
of murder you're right dude when you're
right you're right I don't trust any
girl with hairy legs I mean I can
[ __ ] choke out the would new white
camera guy or Louise with the fake name
over there yeah I'm not buying that with
that fake party
look forward to it bring your own girls
and beard yeah don't a party at your
house yeah don't [ __ ] me on girls I just
want to bait us there and then [ __ ]
scalp the white man I know what's going
on dude with a [ __ ] arrow oh dude
what does she want relationship advice
girls with hairy legs oh I'm out didn't
you say wow on a very special King
interesting all right now can't handle
it no very good girls like it makes me
sick
I'm gonna go to hell probably haven't
made a lot of poor choices in my life
already half there brother
I knew my legs felt warm you get any
dates coming up man that's that ruin my
day
what do you got I don't feel like doing
comedy anymore I'm gonna be I said 26
I'm gonna be in a Lafayette Louisiana
the day after Christmas doing home for
the holidays and doing a show out there
do want to show out there we're gonna do
a fundraiser - um
some of the proceeds are going to good
fight foundation dozens char-char
poori is charity you got this how are we
doing out there yeah I mean yeah -
percents governor's charity and then the
rest else you take home but uh Wow some
I'm gonna give some of the money with
proceeds going some though bro we don't
know the cost of the [ __ ] to put the
thing
now you get yours broke [ __ ] you
so yeah we're doing a uh we are doing
I'm doing a show at the in Lafayette
Louisiana December 26 and tickets on
sale at the Avon calm / tour and then
December 10th that The Wiltern here in
Los Angeles downtown that's gonna be fun
man I'm in town I'm gonna go for sure
are you yeah hell yeah you might have to
jump up there though yeah dog they'll be
fun every Co wanna be cool man I'm at
the ice house Thursday night this comes
out Thursday job and friends and then
uninvited so I'm you know I don't do you
do it
be at home do it well then do it I'll be
at home join in these videos I just
wonder that's Vanessa hair on her legs I
already knew you'd say no that's what I
thought
Thursday night ice house but November
I'm in Dallas in Salt Lake City get your
tickets and King indistinct or maybe
come any alive I can't ask for anything
about it anymore to sit and power day
God we're figuring it out well are the
proceeds will go to Thea
[Laughter]
[Music]
the King Mustang
[Music]